every child has a fairy born  just for them tinker's bell was born for  you  it's just about  she's in a hurry to grow up  he dreams of exploring new lands who are  these dirty vagabonds  and what have they done with my children  this is the untold story  of a brother and sister two kindred  adventurers  our alice and  how is he he's still the boss  the lost boy is at your service  [Music]  girl's fingernails and black with dirt  we will make a lady of you yet  alice comes with me  rose you shall pay your debt  i need more time take me away from it  peter don't let life take you down you  just keep floating above it  [Applause]  and what are your names  we can all use a little extra courage  now  [Music]  it's not time to grow our palace  neverest peter  you'll see  you